[موسيقى]
يرقصون ويغنون لاسترضاء الطبيعه ودفع
اذاها عنهم كما يعتقدون كما تشاهدونه هنا
وجزء من طقوس قبيله الشننوا تعالوا لنتعرف
على قصه جديده من عادات
عام 2019 اجتاحت الاف الحرائق غابات
الامازون وهو اكبر عدد من الحرائق تشهده
هذه المنطقه خلال 10 سنوات تقريبا
وقاعده في امك
[موسيقى]
الحال في الامازون لم يخلو من الاعتبارات
السياسيه ايضا الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جير بول اثار غضب القبيله بعد تصريحات
اعترف خلالها بان بلاده لا تمتلك الموارد
اللازمه لاخماد الحرائق وبان هذه القبائل
تقيم على ارض غير منتجه قبيله الشناني وهو
غيرها من القبائل المقيمه في المنطقه
اعتبرت هذه التصريحات مهينه
[موسيقى]
فايزي يعمل
غابه المطريه في العالم كانت قضيه رئيسيه
في الانتخابات البرازيليه السابقه فخلال
ولايه بوسنارو التي وصلت فيها اصداء
الحرائق الى انحاء العالم ارتفع معدل قطع
اشجار الغابات البرازيليه بنسبه 57%
مقارنه بما كانت عليه في العقد السابق كما
خفضت الحكومه التمويل البيئي 71%
كل هذه الاجراءات دعت سكان الغابات
للاستغفار والصلاه طلبان لحمايه ارضهم
وغاباتهم وحمايه سكان الارض فغابات
الامازون تمتص كميات هائله من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون الذي يسبب الاحتباس الحراري لكن
عند ازاله الغابات يتم اطلاقه في الغلاف
الجوي
فيفاقم من ازمه تغير المناخ
[موسيقى]